hey guys what's up my name is Daniel and
welcome to D LM model lifestyle now if
you need to my channel please subscribe
and click the bells if you want to miss
anything new now this is a video request
some of you guys asked me hey Daniel I
got a problem with acne and pimples and
please help me out and just tell me how
to get rid of it so this video I'm gonna
tell you 13
tips to get rid of acne and pimples so
let's get into the video
all right now I used to have acne and it
was a huge problem for me especially in
my teenage years oh man
acne is evil they steal your confidence
you know sometimes they're not there and
then they pop up just out of nowhere
they're just there and then they
disappear again you know and just when
you get your confidence back up and you
go to a special event boom they're there
again and sometimes they just want to
stick around for a long time so getting
pimples is normal yes but there are ways
to control it so I'm gonna give you guys
13 tips to get rid of acne and pimples
the first step is stick to a great skin
care routine if you haven't started a
skin care routine yet start right now it
is so important guys to have a
consistent skin care routine now there's
a lot of bad tips and good tips out
there but the biggest reason that you
have acne and pimples is because of
those bacteria under your skin's surface
now when you look at your skin you have
all these small holes in them right and
they need to kind of breathe if you have
any dirt or oil or dead skin cells in
there then yes the chances are that you
might get some pimples so to fix that
you need to have a good basic skin care
routine and you gotta stick to it
because it does take consistency and
patience to improve your skin we all
have different skin types right but a
good skin care routine will improve your
skin over time now there's a few basic
steps that you need to follow in your
skincare routine number one
wash your face two times a day number
two exfoliate twice a week to get rid of
those dead skin cells and number three
moisturize your skin twice a day in the
morning and also before you go to bed
so what are the best products for your
skincare routine well there are a lot of
products out there right and so
everybody's face is a little bit
different and their genes are different
but for me I love all us choice PC for
men they are really really cute that's
my first option second option you can
have a look at teaching hanley they're
really good as well and then if you have
a low budget you can try out the
products from L'Oreal men now I'll add
the links of all the products in the
video description down below so you can
have a look at them and do your own
research as well now let's move on and
then sleep you gotta sleep more
consistently because acne breakouts and
other skin anomalies are common
byproducts of sleep deprivation so you
sleep between 6 & 8 hours a day it
should be fine
and then get the right supplements
probiotics zinc and more antioxidants
all of these will really help you to
fight acne now research shows that there
are two superstar ingredients that
reduces acne they are benzoyl peroxide
and also salicylic acid so if you use
products with these ingredients in them
then it will really help you to take
care of the acne and pimples but just be
careful and check out what other
ingredients is also in the product
before you just go ahead and buy it
that's why I love Paula's choice
products they have this clear range
where they build their product range
around these two ingredients they have
regular strength products and then they
also created extra strength products for
those really stubborn acne
another good tip is to wash your
pillowcase more often there's a lot of
people that only showers in the morning
but that means you've been going on your
day getting a lot of dirt on your face
and then you go to bed on the same
pillowcase every night that's terrible
so wash your pillowcase every now and
then it's also better if you take a
shower at nighttime as well stop
scrubbing your face too hard and too
much it will irritate your skin and it
will make things a lot worse
just wash it gently and when you dry
your face just tap it gently as well eat
the right kinds of food yes you've heard
that saying that says you are what you
eat right well it is true you got to
stay away from all kinds of sugar it is
not only bad for your health and causes
a lot of diseases and it also makes you
fat but it is also bad for your face
because sugar feeds yeast and yeast
feeds Candida also try to stay away from
gluten and all kinds of unhealthy bad
grains you have to remember normal bread
from the store is not normal bread
anymore check out what is really in it
also stay away from bad oils sunflower
canola vegetable oil those are very very
bad words and this brings me to the next
tip
you gotta eat more of the following
foods healthy fats healthy proteins
meaning organic protein and fiber rich
products and then also you got a drink a
lot of water never use thick
moisturizers in any area where you have
acne or pimples because they clog those
pores and they just make things a lot
worse again your skin needs to breathe
right so use lightweight products like
gels and liquids or lotions use a gentle
but effective water-soluble cleanser
twice a day because drying cleansers and
harsh cleansers and scrubs or cleaning
brushes they just make things a lot
worse
[Music]
try to avoid all types of bar cleansers
even if they claim to be soap free
because there's ingredients that keep
the soap in a bar kind of form are
actually the culprits that clogs your
pores then another tip you're probably
doing it right now stop touching your
face take it up yes we get into that
habit we do it without even thinking you
just go through the day and you touch it
and you think and well you've been doing
a lot of stuff of your hands right so it
gathers dirt so it stop touching your
face also start to wash your hands a lot
more you know so for those times when
you do touch your face at least your
hands are cleaner now my last step is if
you keep on struggling with acne and
pimples go and see a dermatologist and
ask for some help and hey remember all
the products that I talked about in this
video is in the video description down
below just to make it a bit easier for
you to go and check them out and to do
your own research now if you liked the
video give it a thumbs up subscribe and
I'll see you in the next video Cheers
you
[Music]